s vary and may not be typical. We do not
make any claims regarding health or
income. As an empowered individual, you
do have options available. We are
honored to continue to share the
teachings of a founding father of the
science of epigenetics. Dr. Joel Wallik,
Bachelor of Science in Plant and Soil
Sciences, Doctor of Veterary Medicine,
four post-doates and pathology,
naturopathic doctor,
This program is for educational
purposes. says only. The content is not
intended to diagnose, treat, cure, or
prevent any diseases, nor is it intended
to take the place of your primary care
physician. The statements in this
program have not been evaluated by the
FDA. Testimonials are shared as
individual experiences of the
individual. Results vary and may not be
typical. We do not make any claims
regarding health or income. As an
empowered individual, you do have
options available. We are honored to
continue to share the teachings of a
founding father of the science of
epigenetics, Dr. Joel Wallik, Bachelor
of Science in Plant and Soil Sciences,
Doctor of Veterary Medicine, Ford postdo
pathology, naturopathic doctor.
Hello everybody. Welcome to Daily with
Doc and Becca. I am your host and
producer, Becca Dukes, and I am excited
to be with you today. So today we have a
very special returning guest joining us
from Sugarland, Texas, Yolanda Bran. And
I think today's conversation is one that
many of us need to hear right now,
even me. Um, you know, life has a way of
presenting challenges, disappointments,
obstacles, and moments that try to
convince us that something isn't
possible, that we can't move forward,
that circumstances determine our future.
Well, folks, what if those thoughts
carry more power than we realize?
And I am excited as we are going to be
exploring
the world of you can, we can, and we
will. Now, our guest today is the
dynamic Yolanda Brown, who is a
motivator, a trainer, and she has been
around the world
helping others get the
motivation and information they need to
start making those changes.
So folks, if you are here because
somebody invited you to be here and you
have more questions about some of the
things that we are going to be
discussing today,
make sure that you get back with the
person that shared this program with you
and tell them thank you. They are going
to be your number one point of contact
to get information. And if you found
this show all on your own and you want
more information, we have a team that is
standing by at 8559493377.
Today's program is being sponsored by
dailywithdoc.com
where we have lots of information to
empower you as an individual to create a
better health journey. So, without
further ado, I am excited to have with
me and adding her to the screen the
beautiful Yolanda Brown. Hello, Yolanda.
Thank you so much for joining us here
today.
>> Oh, you know what, Becca? Thank you and
your team for allowing me to be of
service. So, I am so excited to be here.
And you know guys, whenever you get a
chance, for those of you that are
listening, please give a shout out to
this team because they're taking the
time out to deliver so many different
speakers each and every day to help you
become that best version of yourself.
So, thank you guys. Thank each and every
one of you.
>> Well, thank you, Yolanda. as you know
there there's so many different aspects
of becoming the best self that we can be
whether it's physical, mental,
emotional. Um today we're going to be
talking more of the mental emotional
>> side of it and I am so excited as you
have
a great book that you read that is has
brought a lot of light to this subject.
So, I'm just going to go ahead and turn
that over to you and then as we have
questions, folks, if you want to raise
your hand, you can raise your hand at
the end if there's time. We're going to
be going through some questions and
answers. But without further ado, Miss
Yolanda Brown. All right. Thank you so
much, Becca, again. And guys, I want you
to know that as Becca indicated, I'm
going to be really talking from a book
um by Raymond Hwell, and it's called
Working with the Law. And I don't know
if if this happens to you, but sometimes
when I'm reading a book, I get inspired.
And when I start underlining words and
paragraphs and start starring things and
then there is this still small voice
that I get um and it says that you
should share this.
And I've gotten to the point now where I
listen to that still small voice. And I
shared part of this on um the daily dose
call. This call allows me to go a little
bit more into what I really want people
to get. And so I hope today that you
will get it. So I'll be doing quite a
few quotes from um the book working with
the law. And I want to share with you a
poem that he started off his book with
or this chapter when I was reading. is a
declaration
that Hwell himself opens with and he
says
he can who thinks he can. It is God's
will that man should not only use but
enjoy every good in the universe. The
law of God denies man nothing.
Denies us nothing.
So I I want you to understand that God
denies us nothing.
denies you nothing. Now whatever your
belief may be for me it's God and I will
be using that today. So but I just want
you to know that's really important that
that means whatever you have been
telling yourself
you cannot have you cannot do you cannot
become. If you've been telling yourself
that that is not God's word over your
life
and that is fear talking. And today
we're going to deal with fear. So we
have to realize that we're all born for
greatness. You've heard many speakers,
influencers say it. We are born to be
rich. And whether or not you define rich
in terms of dollars and cents, the
deeper truth is this. You were created
for abundance.
You were born to be the best version of
yourself, not anyone else of yourself.
But here's what no one tells you.
Greatness is not delivered to your front
door.
It is developed.
It is cultivated.
It is drawn out of you little by little,
layer by layer as you do the work of
your self-discovery.
Hollywood puts it this way in his book.
He says true self-help,
self-discovery,
self-nowledge and the proper instruction
is applying one's faculties and using
one's forces will advance any person.
Practice will ensure efficiency.
Using will bring forth results.
Success is within the reach of every
aspiring person.
So, did you catch that? Success is
within the reach of every aspiring
person. Not every person with talent,
not every lucky person, not every person
that says that I got this. No, it's
every aspiring person. Aspiring simply
means
desiring it, to desire earnestly,
to reach for it, to keep trying and
going after it, to do it.
So that means that you qualify today.
That means right now as you are in this
Zoom meeting room, you qualify.
So Hollywood reminds us of something
that James Allen said and you probably
heard this quote before. You are today
where your thoughts have bought you. You
will be tomorrow where your thoughts
take you.
You see our thoughts are not idle
passengers in our lives. They are
drivers. What we consistently think
about,
we cons consistently move towards.
This is not wishful thinking guys. This
is it's the law. It is the law and we
all need to be working with the law.
So I ask you this today. Do you wish to
succeed? Do you wish to love more
deeply? Do you wish to serve more
powerfully?
Do you wish to give more freely? Do you
wish to build your business bigger and
better?
Because I say to you, you can. You have
all the essentials within yourself to
succeed, to love, to give, and to give
hope.
They're already there placed within you
by the God who created you and who
denies you nothing.
So to advance is the law. To be true to
yourself and to the law which governs
you, you simply must advance. For
advancement is success. It is the law's
intention that you shall move forward,
not backward.
Hollywood states that in his book. So I
want you to think about that. The
universe is not a neutral is not neutral
about your growth. The law that governs
life, spiritual, mental, and natural
laws are designed for you to move
forward.
You may delay your progress. You may
have to take some detours
and you may stall for a reason or you
may stall for a season.
You may stall for a lifetime.
But it's you.
But in the end, you will be compelled to
move forward at some point in time,
especially in the direction of your
soul's growth.
That's pretty deep. But I want you to
encourage to be encouraged today. I want
you to know that no matter how long
you've been stuck. No matter how far you
feel that you have moved away from where
you want to be, the law is on your side.
It is pulling you forward.
You can achieve your ambition.
You can aim high and build well. You can
build yourself. build your business. You
can build relationships with intention
and excellence.
Napoleon Hill in his landmark book, I'm
sure each of you may have read it at
some point in time or heard somebody say
it, think and grow rich. Whatever the
mind can conceive and believe it can
achieve.
So hold that image in your mind.
Whatever vision you have for your life,
your business, your family, hold it, fix
it in your mind, see it clearly every
single day. Because a vision held
faithfully
paired with consistent action moving
forward is a vision that must come to
pass.
Now, that's not positive thinking.
That's the law.
So what is success really?
So before I go any further, I want to
ask you that question. What does success
mean to you?
And I want you to take a moment. And if
you have pen and paper in front of you,
you can write it down. Or if not, you
can just begin to think about it and and
write it down later because you really
want to know what does success mean to
you? Not for your spouse, not for your
children, not for your relatives, but
for you. Is it prosperity? Is it
personal freedom? Is it a dream coming
true? Is it a deep deep sense of
purpose? Is it great relationships?
Is it watching your children thrive?
Whatever it is, it is your definition of
success.
Hol states that is not success is not
defined in terms of money, position,
fame or wealth. Although it may include
all of these, true genuine success of
the largest kind lies in the results
obtained. harvest reaped and distributed
to so that our fellow beings, our
business partners, our friends at large
are benefited and the world
is enriched.
I love that.
I think that is so powerful. Real
success is not just what we accumulate.
So many of us tie success to what we
have. The cars we drive, where we live,
you know, who we hang around, all of
that. It is what you give out. It is
what you distribute.
That's success.
It's the harvest you bring and share.
Success. Think about what this business
is all about. Think about what you do
each and every day. The people that you
help. Success that enriches only you is
not the fullness of success but the
success that enriches the world around
you.
That is what we're after.
So for today, let's let's agree on this
definition if you will.
Success is personal and business
advancement
and increase. Moving forward in every
area that matters to you, no one else to
you in a way that serves and uplifts
others
around you.
I like that.
Maybe you can use that definition, too.
What is it that you truly want to
achieve in this business
in life?
What is that thing you have been
dreaming about and you have not yet
reached?
And then let me ask the harder question.
What's holding you back?
Now, if you're honest, and I believe you
can be, because nobody's listening to
what's in here but you, or what you may
be writing down, the answer for most of
us, you know, we're holding ourselves
back. But it's fear.
It's fear. It's that enemy that we call
fear.
And it has many faces. The fear of
failure, the fear of what people think,
the fear of what people are saying, the
fear of success and what it will demand
of me. Do I want to do and be busy and
do that type of work? We we don't know.
But we put all of this in our heads. The
fear of not having enough, the fear of
not being enough, the fear of not being
smart enough, or the fear of not being
ready.
Maybe all of that is staying in this
head of yours. Get it out. Go back to
what you're holding. That success that
you want to go after. Holl says that
fear paralyzes our mental forces which
must be free and active if we are to
avoid calamity.
You see, when a person's mind is
confused by fear,
Raymond Hol says he is in no condition
to accept an opportunity. He won't be
ready for it. If it's staring you in the
face, you won't be ready for it.
Fear does not just make you
uncomfortable. It paralyzes you.
The very mental and spiritual forces you
need to move forward are paralyzed. So
when fear has that on you, you can't
recognize an opportunity,
not even if it's standing right in front
of you. You can't think clearly. You
can't act boldly.
Fear clouds everything.
But the word of God speaks directly to
this. The apostle Paul
writing to a young leader named Timothy
who was facing enormous fear said, "God
has not given us a spirit of fear but of
power and of love
and of a sound mind."
That's pretty powerful. Power, love, a
sound mind.
That is your inheritance. That is what
God has placed within each and every one
of us, within you. Not being timid, not
being paralyzed, not being confused, but
power, love, and soundness,
a sound mind.
No good thing will God, the law,
withhold from them that walk uprightly,
says Hollowwell in his book. And you've
heard that from so many other authors
and speakers.
We all put it in our own words. But this
book just spoke to me and I want to use
his words because I want to give credit
where credit is due. That those words
just lifted off the page.
So whatever your belief system is,
wherever you find your source and your
supply, I want you to hear this.
The good things you desire are not being
withheld from you by the universe. They
are been being delayed by your fear. And
today, we're going to choose to walk
through that fear to the other side.
Are you willing to do that with me? Are
you willing to walk through it?
So, I'm going to tell you a story that's
in the book, Working with the Law. And
Hollywood
frames this by saying there were two
boys drove to the river one day
challenging one another to swim across
to the other side. So they both dove in
and swam with strong steady strokes. The
lead swimmer kept his eyes forward. Sat
on the shore, the other shore. Stroke
after stroke, he focused on where he was
going, not where he had been. When he
walked out on the bank, dripping and
victorious, he turned back to look for
his friend. But his friend was nowhere
near. He looked more carefully, and
there he saw him in the distance back on
the shore where they had started.
That's where he was.
And when they met afterwards, the boy
who swam across asked, "How was it that
you did not follow me across?"
The boy who turned back said, "After I
got about halfway out, I looked back and
I saw how far I had come and I was
afraid I couldn't make it. So, I turned
back.
and the boy who had crossed something
that I want you never to forget.
Why didn't you think to look forward as
I did? I saw only the shore coming
closer and closer with each stroke that
I was taking. And was it not just as
hard to turn back
as it was to continue onto your goal?
Oh my goodness, how many of us are
halfway across the river of our dreams
and we have made the fatal mistake of
looking backward. We see how far we have
come and think, "Oh, oh god, I may not
make I may not make that next level. I I
this may not happen." So, we just kind
of chill, kind of turn back to where we
are and stay where we are. And that's
what we do. But I ask you, is turning
back truly safe?
Is staying where you are truly
comfortable
or is it just familiar?
So let's look forward. The shore is
closer than we think. That next level is
closer than you think. So just keep
swimming.
You can.
So it truly is the power of I can. So
catch the spirit of the words I can. And
you have the key to a successful
attitude. Know you can succeed. and
proceed to think, live, and act in such
a strong conviction. You may search
everywhere to discover the mystic secret
of success only to find in the end it is
all contained in two little words.
And Raymond Hollowwell ends the quote
with I can.
Two words,
the most powerful two words in the
English language. Well, I would say for
me the most powerful two words in the
English language happens to be thank you
and then I am and then I would say I can
are two most powerful words.
So why don't you say it right now?
Nobody's hearing you. Y'all on mute. You
can say it out loud. I can
say it again. I can.
You see, one state is largely determined
by one's mental attitude. Do you believe
that? Many of you didn't do it. Maybe
because you don't believe it or maybe
just because you just don't want to do
it right now. Either way, you should do
it at some point to say I can.
You see, there are people that radiate
with discouragement, gloom, failure
because they've accepted the I can't
attitude. You know these people at some
point in time we might have been one of
those people.
I know I probably was and in some point
at some point and some maybe now
sometimes I may say oh I don't know if I
can do that or not.
Let's be honest with ourselves.
We meet them all the time.
But then there are those who are
positives who emanates that success
through a cheerful confident energetic I
can attitude.
Holl says one gravitates to adversity
and the other attracts the very best. In
essence, you know, one draws people in
and the other one keeps them out.
So you choose.
You see I I can't person actually repel
us instinctively. It's automatic because
they are as Hol puts it out of tune with
the divine order of things. The I can't
attitude violates the very law of
advancement. But the I can individual
and we want to associate with them. We
are happy to associate with them. We
want to do business with them. We want
them around us. Why? Because their
spirit is aligned
with the creation's intention
to do well, to be good
because we all create this individual
environment, this atmosphere.
Hallelu says that we have our own
individual atmosphere. He says, "Let us
seek to build up a strong positive I can
attitude which will lead us to success."
Then ask yourself, what do people sense
when they enter into an I can't
environment atmosphere or when they
enter to an I can environment or
atmosphere.
So let's build our lives with I can.
Let's build our business with I can.
Let's fill our teams with I can people
and let's fill our heads with the I can
attitude and let's fill our hearts with
I can and let's see what happens.
We have to hold a mental picture of what
we want. We have to realize that this I
can is the attitude. But how do we
cultivate it and sustain it?
So I'm going to give you a clear next
step and it's in the book. Olive will
states make you make a mental picture.
You've heard that from many of speakers.
So we all just borrow from each other.
But so basically you make a mental
picture. You hold it
in your mind what you are aspiring to
achieve. You see it clearly. You see it
specifically. You see it daily.
So this isn't a new age mysticism. This
isn't ancient.
Well, yeah, it is. is ancient spiritual
wisdom. That's what this is.
So, if you think about it, if you go
back and look at Proverbs 29:18, it
says, "Where there is no vision, the
people perish." You've heard people say
that a lot.
But vision isn't optional. Did you
realize that it is not optional? It is
survival.
It is the difference between a life that
merely happens
and the life you intentionally create.
Dr. Norman Vincent Peele, whose classic
book, I'm sure we've all read it or
heard somebody talk about it, the power
of positive thinking, taught, "Formulate
and stamp indebtedly on your mind a
mental picture of yourself succeeding.
Hold this picture tenaciously and never
permit permit it to fade. Your mind will
seek to develop this picture. Hold that
picture, the good picture,
so that the mind can develop it every
single day. Take the time to see
yourself on the other side. See yourself
with that thriving business. See
yourself with that great relationship.
See that see yourself with that person
that you are becoming.
And see your goals as they are already
accomplished.
Not wishful dreaming.
But it's faith.
Faith is seeing what you Faith is seeing
what has not yet appeared
in the physical world
and calling it into being.
You can never fail if you never give up.
Got to keep on trying
each day. We got to keep on trying.
Success after all is is a collection of
our many good results that we have. All
of the good that we're doing each and
every day. Every time you try and you
fall short, you're still accumulating
results, right? You're still doing
something. You're still moving forward.
You're still learning. So this is why
the law is so important because see
there's a thief
inside
of our homes, inside of our minds.
So and this thief
lives
and just strives and works with us daily
day by day by day. doesn't announce
itself.
It doesn't break down the door to get
into our homes. Just kind of sneaks in
and then it disguises itself as I'll do
that later. Oh, I'll do that on Monday.
It's Friday. I'll wait till Monday and
get that done. Or you know what? I'm
just not ready yet.
So that thief that's in your house and
in your mind is procrastination.
We've all dealt with it. Some of us are
dealing with it today. Hollywood says
that procrastination kills ambition. Oh,
kills your dreams. It kills it. It gets
one into the habit of indecision which
causes failure. You do nothing.
You do nothing.
So, did you hear that? It doesn't just
delay your your success. It kills your
ambition.
It robs you
of being successful.
It robs you of making decisions.
Benjamin Franklin said, "Never leave
till tomorrow that what you can do
today."
Simple.
It's direct. And it's a quote that is
timeless.
So in your business, in your life,
practice making your decisions clearly
and promptly. Take care of the small
questions that come to you each and
every day. They are training your
decision making muscle.
Yep, you got that muscle.
And when the big questions come, they
will come and your muscle will be
strong.
See, there's no reason the most
successful leaders in the world share a
common trait.
But there is one reason why they share
this common trait.
Decisiveness.
They don't have all the information.
They don't have all of the cert
certainties around it, but they decide.
They act
clearly, promptly, and boldly.
William James put it this way. Act as if
what you do makes a difference.
Because it does.
Think about what we do here at our at
our business. It makes a difference.
It does. So, make a decision. Make it
today that you're going to build your
business bigger and better than what it
is today.
That you're going to work with people
where they are. That you can think it
through and decide,
commit, and move forward.
The world responds to those who move.
Opportunity knocks, but it doesn't wait
on the porch for you all day. So don't
let procrastinate sneak into your house.
Let procrastination know that you can
decide, you can act and you can begin
and you can do it now.
And you know your most valuable asset in
this business in life
that you want to do things now because
that valuable asset is time.
What do you do with your spare time?
How do you spend it?
Where do you spend it?
Do you give your time value? Holla will
ask that question in his book. And I can
tell you that time of all the resources
that we have, time is the only one that
cannot be replenished.
Money lost can be earned back.
Relationships strained can be restored.
But time spent
is spent forever. Our
success depends on the use of our time.
And Hollywood says that that time that
we could be spending sometimes we do
not. But he says that if our success
depends on the use of our time. And he
calls this byproducts, those odd
moments, those spare minutes like the
waiting room or the early morning before
everyone else wakes up, the 15 minutes
before you go into bed. What are you
doing with those byproducts that time?
What are you doing with that?
He says the real success of some people
started in in those odd moments. Abraham
Lincoln studied law by fire light in the
evenings after a full day's work. How
many of us get home and we're tired and
we know we need to make a phone call in
our business or do something in our
business and we're like, "Okay,
procrastination is in our house. We'll
do it tomorrow."
Oprah Winfrey has spoken about using
every available moment to learn, to
read, to grow. You see, the most
successful people are not the ones with
the most hours.
They are the ones who use the hours they
have most faithfully.
So, when you're working your business,
are you spending the time on income
producing activities? Are you making
calls, connecting with people,
talking with people that's in your
business about strategy, about what's
going on, or just, you know what, just
saying thank you, following up, building
relationships,
or are you busy being busy?
Only you can answer those questions. You
see, there's a difference between
activity and productivity. Activity
feels good but produces little.
Productivity is intentional, targeted,
and results driven.
So what are you doing with your time?
And what kind of work are you with your
time? Jim Ron, one of the greatest
personal development teachers of our
era, said that time is more valuable
than money. You can get more money, but
you cannot get more time.
That pretty much wraps it up. Honor your
time.
You know,
be wise about your time. Invest your
time. Invest in what brings
you and your world the greatest return.
So, you have to realize that
there are some words here that I want
you to really begin to think about as we
begin to
really realize that
success is the way we learn to use two
valuable things.
Our time and our thought.
Knowledge alone is not success. It is
the way we use that knowledge.
And that's a quote by Raymond Hwell.
You may have read every selfhelp book on
the market. You may know more about
success principles than than I do or
anyone else that's on this zone.
But knowledge unused is just potential
gathering dust.
It is the application of what you know
that creates success.
So why don't you use your time, use your
thoughts, act on what you know. That's
success.
And Holly will add as something that I
need you to hear. When I I I wrote this
down and I put it on a 3x5 card is it
says is important always to remember
that back of all our struggles under the
dust there are the arms of the father
guiding guarding and supporting us.
Whatever you lack the father has.
Whatever you need the father can supply.
Whatever obstacle you encounter, God
within you and about you can overcome
it. Again, you fill in the blanks with
whatever your beliefs are. That's
powerful.
Under the dust of your struggle, beneath
the weight of your fear, behind the
discouragement of your setbacks, there
are arms holding you,
guiding you,
guarding you,
supporting you.
You are not alone in this. You have
never been alone in this. Whatever you
face today in business, in your family,
in your heart, the father has what you
need. The father can supply what you
lack. And God within you, that same
spirit that raised Christ from the dead,
can overcome every obstacle you are
facing.
So, here's what I want you to walk away
with.
Knowing that I can,
you can.
We can.
You can.
If you think you are beaten, you are.
If you think you dare not, you don't.
If you'd like to win but think you
can't, it's almost a cinch. You won't.
If you think you'll lose, you're lost.
For out of the world we find success
begins with a fellow's will.
It's all in the state of mind.
If you think you're outclassed, you are.
You've got to think high to rise
and you've got to be sure of yourself
before you can ever win a prize.
Life's battles don't always go to the
stronger or the faster man.
But soon or late.
And we will normally say but sooner or
later. But the poem says but soon or
late. The man who wins
or the woman who wins
is the man who thinks he can.
You see, I can't.
You can't.
We can. And we will.
But we can only do this together. We
have to change our thoughts. We have to
remember that we are in this to win it
together, not alone. And the way in
which we can do that is to believe in
our products, to believe in our
management, to believe in your sponsor,
to believe in you.
I do.
Do you? Because I know you can. I know
we can and I know we will.
Rebecca, thank you. And Ruth, Ellen, and
I don't see I'm going to start calling
names and I'm going to mess something
up. So, thank each and every one of you.
But I hope you got something from this
today that you can take with you and
move forward. And you know when you
think about failure, fail forward. I
think it was Daniel Zel Washington that
said that once. Fail forward because at
least when you look up, you know you can
get up and you know that you're going
forward.
Don't ever ever think that you can't
because you can't.
>> Yes. Yes. Yes. And I took lots of notes.
And folks, I hope if you were listening,
you were taking notes, too. And I want
to know what with the last 40 minutes
that Yolanda has been speaking about I
can. What stuck out to you most? Go
ahead and put it in the comments. If
you're on a platform that allows you to
write comments. If you're here live with
us, you absolutely can put in the
comments in the chat here live with us.
If you'd like to join us in the future
live, we're here Wednesday, Thursday,
Friday from 12:00 to 1:00 p.m. Pacific,
1 to 2 Mountain, 23 Central, 3:00 to 4
Eastern.
Yolanda,
I love this. And Ruth, Ellen and I have
already um made a plan. We're going to
be listening to this book tonight.
>> Great.
>> So, love to chat with you guys about it
after you listen to it. I mean, there
are some things in that book that's just
real powerful. Yes.
>> Yep.
>> Oh, so many powerful things. And I know
that you just touched on a few of them.
Um, it's just amazing what happens when
we believe we can.
>> Yep. You know, and in in addition to
your question, I want to go back to what
the question that I asked early on. What
does success mean to you? If you got
anybody wants to share that too, that
would be ideal because when you're able
to share what success means to you,
that's where some of that fear is
because we don't want anybody to know
what success means to us because if I
don't achieve it, you know, they may
talk about me, but doesn't matter. If
you don't speak it out, at least to
yourself, then it's never going to it's
never going to happen. So that's you
want to hold it and fix it. So you know,
share share with people of like minds. I
get that. And that's what we all need to
do. And I think you got some like-minded
people on this call.
>> Oh, we absolutely do. I know Lorenza
says that he's definitely going to be
relistening to this message. We have
Hunter doing emojis with a strong and
thankful or powerful and thank you.
Thank you, Hunter. Out on YouTube, um
Olga says, "Without vision, my people
perish." That is so true. in AJ's like
if you wrote repeating what you said, if
you can look up, you can get up.
>> Yeah.
>> So, just a few just a few things as as
we're going through folks,
life is going to throw us a whole lot of
strikes, balls, curve balls, things that
we're going to swing at, but if you
don't stop swinging, you're going to hit
it. So, thank you. Um, Yolanda, I know
Ruse Ellen has her hand up. Ruth Ellen,
do you have a comment or question?
>> Um, mainly comments, I guess. Um, I love
this and, uh, thank you so much for
bringing this topic. We always get
really good feedback when you're on and
people just love what you have to say.
And um you know when you were talking
about you know I can earlier it it took
me back to something. I'm going to try
really hard not to cry.
I um
you got this sister.
>> Yeah you do.
while you're getting that, you know, it
being vulnerable is something that takes
courage
>> and being able to allow others to see
how authentic you are is powerful.
So sometimes when we get emotional, it's
the emotion of courage. And when you
ever heard heard someone and say, "Oh
god, I'm going to have that ugly cry."
That is so powerful because it's just
like letting all of all of what's in out
and let's find a solution to it or I
just needed to get it out. So when I
hear someone or even feel it myself and
say I hope I can get through this
without crying. I want to get through it
without crying. But if I do cry, I know
it's okay because it's going to it's
going to be it's okay because it's who I
am and it's what I'm feeling right now.
And I need you to know that those
feelings are real. So, I hope that gave
you time enough to
>> It did.
>> Yeah, there you go.
>> It did. I'm probably gonna cry, but I'm
not gonna ugly cry on camera. I'll turn
it off
because it's ugly.
Um,
over the last several years, um, I have
had some personal challenges and, um,
some very
catastrophic losses.
you know, I lost my friend, my mother,
and I had a a personal loss all in one
month.
And uh it was devastating.
And this whole time,
my only thoughts were, except for a
couple times, there was a few times I
didn't say this, but tomorrow's always
going to be a better day than
>> And that kept me going.
And it gave me strength and courage.
So I can I will and I do.
>> Absolutely. Absolutely. And the last
part of that I do is what's most
important.
>> We can say that we can and we will, but
if we take no action to do, then we're
just putting words out there,
>> you know. So, thank you for being you
and thank you for doing
>> I'm here, right?
>> Yeah.
>> Beautiful.
>> Whatever it takes. And I didn't do it
alone. And you know, that's the other
thing is, you know, you said having good
people around you to help you
so they can hold the mirror up when you
think you can't and you can see that you
can. So that's really really important.
And um there was another Hunter uh had
another comment. Um
well Harry um healer from Rumble says
you have shared your words from your
heart. Yolanda God's wisdom. Thanks.
Much light and love to you.
>> A thanks. Um,
>> Rebecca already read Olga's comment and
then Hunter
says, "Whether you think you can or
think you can't, you're right."
And that is a very true statement.
>> Yep. It is,
>> you know, and and when we when we think
about guys, when we think about
what we can and what we can't do, if we
would just stop and pause a moment and
think only about what we can do and if
we don't do anything, what happens?
So, I'm always, always, always, always,
always, I know that there's always,
always, always something to be thankful
for. It could be the least little thing.
And if I do nothing else today in my
business, if I do nothing else but make
a phone call to someone who's been
ordering products or or like Tuesday, I
made calls to people that had not
ordered in a while. And I just called
them and I said, "I'm just calling to
see how you doing to say thank you."
And a person has already placed an
order. I didn't ask them to place an
order. I was just calling them to say
thank you because I appreciate whatever
they have done to take care of
themselves. And that was basically what
I said. Thank you for taking care of
yourself. Health is most important. If
there's anything I can do for you,
please don't hesitate to give me a call.
Voicemail texting is your friend.
>> Use it and use it wisely. But go back
and look in your organization for those
that may not have ordered but maybe once
or twice or and you've not reached out.
Some of us don't want to reach out but
you should and just just call and say
thank you guys. You will be surprised.
People just want a connection and that's
what I tell people to do all the time
and I don't tell people to do something
that I'm not willing to do. So I do it
as well.
Yes, that's very true. Um, real quick,
Olga says, uh, we don't know what
tomorrow brings, but we know who holds
tomorrow.
>> It's very true.
>> And our powers and u thank you Olga for
your comment to me. Thank you. Um, and
you know, I learned a long time ago. I
have a coin
says 10 minutes.
You can do anything for 10 minutes. Make
phone calls for 10 minutes. Straighten
up your office for 10 minutes. Just set
a timer and do it. And that will help
break that procrastination.
>> Yep.
Yep.
>> Someone used that one on me.
>> Yeah, she's used that one on me several
times.
I was trying to move. Pack boxes and
move.
>> Yeah. Just 10 minutes.
>> Yes.
>> Great.
>> Um, and Jelina says, "Powerful." Harry
says, "I think I can. I think I can. I
know I can. I can. I believe I can."
>> So, you are absolutely right, Harry. And
Bruce says, "We love you, Rosellen."
Which, yes, we do.
>> So,
>> love you, too.
Thank you so much Yolanda for spending
this hour with us. We greatly appreciate
your time every single time as you are
delivering
value and helping us with daily with doc
de deliver more value and more than just
the physical health but also the mental
and emotional health. Greatly appreciate
you. Well, again, I appreciate the
opportunity to be of service and anytime
that I can help, I will. And to those
that are listening in, I just want to
thank you because that lets me know that
you are wanting and willing to do
something about your business and your
life. And guys, you you are out there
every day giving an example. Um
I AJ asked as asked a a question earlier
today before we got started and he's
helping a young lady who has seen
results already but had never ever taken
any type of supplementation
or nutrition if you want to if you
prefer to use that. So we don't know
what people know and what they don't
know until we share. And then when you
see that what you do matters
because it does
if he didn't share with another person
that he can take with him the rest of
his life but he knows that there are mo
more that he will share with. So I
that's what I want you to think about.
It only starts with one person. Go back
to your very very first day when you did
this you started this business. go back
to your very first day when you helped
the first person. you hold on to that
because that's that happy place and
that's where you can build from because
if you did it once you can do it again
and the fact is once you keep doing it
you others are going to do it and that's
how your business and that's how your
message grows of hope and of love and of
I can
>> absolutely and you know when you have
that hope you have that I love that That
feeling of I can and you share it with
others.
>> Yep.
>> It gives you purpose,
a strong purpose.
And I absolutely love what we do here on
Daily with Doc and even in my in my own
practice.
So folks, let's give it up for Miss
Yolanda Brown from the Majestic Eagle.
Sore soar, sore, and Shirley in Texas.
Tell Raymond hello for us. Give us some
give him some of our love as well.
>> I most certainly will. And if I can get
the team up on the screen with me with
us, that'd be greatly appreciated as I
am so thankful that I have been able to
surround myself with people that are I
can people like Albert down in South
Africa as he is our gatekeeper joining
us sometimes in the middle of the night
depending on the time zone or the time
of the year in the changes in time zone.
Thank you so much, Albert, for all that
you do. And Ruth Ellen, my executive
marketing director, who is behind the
scenes, even when she's not here, but
she is here. So, thank you so much, Ruth
Ellen, for all that you do and getting
this broadcast out on the different
streams. and also AJ who is our
digital marketing manager
and helping us be where you are. So, no
matter where you're listening to us
from, if you've got a way to let us know
that you're there with a comment, a
like, a love, a share,
subscribe,
that's how we know that you're there.
and we want to make sure that you don't
miss an episode of empowering
information brought to you by Daily with
Doc and Becca. Thank you everybody for
joining us and again get back with a
person share this program with you and
if there is no one to thank we have a
team at 855-9493377.
You can.
And if you want to be part of something
greater than yourself and have a greater
purpose on this while you're on this
earth,
we're here for you. 855 9493377
or again the person that shared this
program with you. So until next time,
bye for now.
Thank you Yolanda. Thank you.
>> Thank you team.
This program is for educational purposes
only. The content is not intended to
diagnose, treat, cure, or prevent any
diseases, nor is it intended to take the
place of your primary care physician.
The statements in this program have not
been evaluated by the FDA. Testimonials
are shared as individual experiences of
the individual. Results vary and may not
be typical. We do not make any claims
regarding health or income. As an
empowered individual, you do have
options available. We are honored to
continue to share the teachings of a
founding father of the science of
epigenetics, Dr. Joel Wallik, Bachelor
of Science in Plant and Soil Sciences,
Doctor of Veterary Medicine, four
post-doates in pathology, naturopathic
doctor
This program is for educational purposes
only. The content is not intended to
diagnose, treat, cure, or prevent any
diseases, nor is it intended to take the
place of your primary care physician.
The statements in this program have not
been evaluated by the FDA. Testimonials
are shared as individual experiences of
the individual. Results vary and may not
be typical. We do not make any claims
regarding health or income. As an
empowered individual, you do have
options available. We are honored to
continue to share the teachings of a
founding father of the science of
epigenetics, Dr. Joel Wallik, Bachelor
of Science in Plant and Soil Sciences,
Doctor of Veterary Medicine, for
post-docctorates in pathology,
naturopathic doctor.
This program is for educational purposes
only. The content is not intended to
diagnose, treat, cure, or prevent any
diseases, nor is it intended to take the
place of your primary care physician.
The statements in this program have not
been evaluated by the FDA. Testimonials
are shared as individual experiences of
the individual. Results vary and may not
be typical. We do not make any claims
regarding health or income. As an
empowered individual, you do have
options available. We are honored to
continue to share the teachings of a
founding father of the science of
epigenetics, Dr. Dr. Joel Wallik,
Bachelor of Science in Plant and Soil
Sciences, Doctor of Veterary Medicine,
Ford Post-Do and Pathology, Naturopathic
Doctor